hey guys I'm Bryce ander and Witney
Carson is here and we are live hi
everybody this is Facebook live yeah how
are you doing I'm good how are you I'm
good if you've got questions for Whitney
drop them in the comments below
we'll be getting them here I'll be
asking them for you but I have some
questions in my own to kick off this
interview okay let's do it
are you enjoying a little bit of time
off from Dancing with the Stars right
now I am I'm enjoying my time off for
sure I've had an amazing summer I
actually went back home to Utah where I
currently live now but we just have been
having so much fun just vacationing I
actually did my own show in Utah so yeah
so my coworker Lindsey Arnold and I we
did a show together it knows actually
our husband's idea to do it funny enough
but it was just really funny we were
like looking at each other and they were
talking about dance and we're like this
is so weird I'm like I can't believe
that you were talking about leaps and
turns like stop anyway yeah so I did
that and it was awesome it was just like
a one-night thing and it was called born
and raised Utah so that was really fun
and yeah so I worked a little bit and I
vacationed a little bit and it was
awesome nice you're in your last few
weeks right before the madness starts
again I know so I'm actually waiting to
hear if you know when I'm gonna meet my
partner so it should be in the next few
days hopefully soon hopefully a good one
hopefully he's nice so I'm just kind of
waiting until they give me the heads up
to go but we've been we've written a
couple rehearsals but nothing too crazy
yet the madness hasn't started yet not
quite yet yeah do you have any celebs
you're thinking of that you're like I
will hope it's this person I helped I
was thrilled I've got a ton Channing
Tatum Zac Efron
Chris Hemsworth Liam Hemsworth
anything's worth
Andy Hemsworth really bring him on in um
no I I'm just at this point like I've
been blessed to have amazing partners so
I think at this point just somebody
who's really nice and really willing to
work hard and I think one of the you
know Olympians would be awesome since
yeah it's just happened I mean anybody
over there like Michael Phelps um but
I'm
they open to anybody who's just willing
to work hard yeah we've heard a lot of
rumors about the lady Olympians but not
so many yeah beans we're hitting a lot
of the gymnasts names being thrown
around like Simone biles oh that would
be awesome I really hope she decides to
do it but I it's so funny cuz I usually
hear tons of rumors by now and I've
heard zip like zero so if you have any
any Intel let me know I've heard the -
I've heard are Simone biles and Teresa
Giudice so no guys for you and
unfortunately I know but element of
surprise surprise I guess yeah had some
pretty good partners like they've never
given you a dud you've had Cody Simpson
Alfonzo Crystal's Carlos Pena Vega and
Von Miller yeah yeah I've been pretty
dang lucky I know I'm like let's keep
this Luck row and until like a lots more
season it's time for another mirror ball
trophy for you I think it is yeah it's
time I mean it's been what three seasons
seasons three seasons since I've had one
and I think it's time comes back come
back around got it come all right we're
getting fan questions now Carol wants to
know how did you like Dancing with a
bond this past season I loved dancing
move on he is just a big because he's
all got a swag and he's like just huge
massive but he is just so nice and he's
so down to earth and we just had a lot
of fun I think at the beginning he
wanted to have way too much fun so I
think we like once we like crack down
the whip and like actually like got him
in there and like he was just working
his butt off you really wanted to make
it you know to the end so I think our
relationship was just really unique and
just fun and he just actually just
texted me he wants me to come to a table
so I'm so excited I'm like I'm a Broncos
fan now for life
now you get to he was in your world and
now you get to go to his world exactly
but I'm gonna be on the sidelines like
pointy-toe what are you doing
straighten your legs all right kate says
this is your season Whitney we're all
rooting for you
so season 23 coming up yeah do you know
of any like what can we expect from
season 23 do you know anything yet
I really don't know anything but I am
just super excited that the
are awesome where they just make the
show new and unique every single season
so I think we have a couple of
opportunities where we can do feature
performances now oh cool so like the
pros will actually be able to like
create something with another pro so I
think that's kind of cool because now it
gives us a try a chance like use our
creativity to the fullest get another
Emmy nomination under your belt I know
I'm like but no I'm just super excited
to get in there and just take risks and
you know just really show that my
partner can dance and just make them
shine this season
so alright Isaac says what's your
favorite music to dance to
so fairies to dance to that's always
hard I always I always just listen to
the radio like whenever I'm in the car
or just hanging around and just look at
the songs that I really love and really
take - and it's funny like some people
just like listen to music and they just
kind of like jam out but I'm like
thinking of steps like choreo like
choreo like as I'm listening to the
music so it all really just depends like
I really like really passionate music
really dramatic and then I also really
like fun and uplifting and just kind of
chill music but so it all kind of
depends on my mood I guess what's your
favorite dance style to choreograph and
teach a partner I'll tell you what the
hardest one is very the hardest one to
teach is actually samba okay you
wouldn't really think that because it's
just so cut it's just kind of like slow
and like you kind of hang back with the
actual technique takes years for people
to perfect it's got it it's just cuz
it's so foreign to their bodies
but so that's the hardest part you have
to match the rhythm with the technique
and that's the hardest bit so we usually
just try to not get that we please not
sound but anything about samba
but yeah but I really like teaching
tango I think that's super you're
passionate and they usually pick up
tango pretty quick because it's all just
steps and really sharp flicks but yeah
got it all right Nicki says spill spill
the tea who's your favorite partner you
have to have one oh my god you do that I
feel like you could safely say all fawns
are just cuz you took home the
Mirrorball trophy I know I usually do
that you just to be safe Isaiah Vaughn
but I try not to specify anybody because
it's like okay so tell me what your
favorite sibling is like that and then
you're like changes every day it does
the changes every day but yeah I've been
blessed with really amazing partners so
I'd say all of them
Dale wants to know when did you start
dancing because we knew you from So You
Think You Can Dance before we knew you
from Dancing with the Stars yeah so I
started dancing when I was a little
little girl my mom put me in when I was
three years old and I think she wanted
to live vicariously through me got it
cuz she loved it and she could tell that
I really loved it because I could just
not stop moving ever since I was little
so she put me in dance class and
absolutely loved it I started with tap
then I went to jazz and hip-hop and
ballet and ballroom eventually when I
was about nine years old Wow
the ripe old age of nine and I just
remember like it was a weird thing with
boys then right like the boys had kids
yeah and but you had to be so
comfortable around them and yet to like
touch their hand and they just touch
your waist and so I would cry every day
to write home I'm like please don't make
me go please and she I'm really glad
that she made me go home he does got
over that phase and now I am where I am
yeah thanks I know thanks mom for that
that was a little random but anyway so
yeah what is your mom think about where
you have wound up because I can't
imagine when she put you into dance
classes that she thought oh she'd be
dancing on TV no um she's extremely
proud you should see her she's like my
number one fan on Twitter Instagram
Facebook if something's happening you
better know that she's gonna know about
it and she on talking about she's like
one of those moms she's so awesome I
Whitney's mom I'm guessing you're
watching he's watching live right now
she's probably commenting like I would
need like here today she's so cute she's
awesome back to dancing Styles what is
your favorite just personal this is my
favorite style of dance so like okay so
if I were to go into like a ballroom and
they said dance something for us yes I
probably would do
right now I'd probably do a jive
I Drive just because it's super like
energetic kinda one it's kind of early
in the morning so I kind of have more
energy than not and I have a good song
in my head right now that would be good
for it and yeah always choreographic
yeah always choreographing my mind is
always working it's a little ad D that's
fine I think it's working out for you
yeah yeah I think it's stood right
Rhonda says costumes on dancing are so
great you have a favorite costume before
the costumes are incredible you guys
like the Wardrobe team is spectacular
they make those costumes in less than
four days and they make them for
everybody like it's nuts I have to say
my favorite costume I have a lot of them
but like my most like iconic I think is
when I did the Carlton with Alphonso
that's got to be my favorite dance and
just like the dress itself was just so
simple but it was so just like it's just
so iconic to the number and it's just
totally fit what we were doing so I'd
have to say that one that is just I
actually stole it so just don't tell
anybody because I loved it so much
frame it one day in your house yeah I
will the Carlton you're also approaching
one year of marriage January how is the
last year of newlywed life been it's
been so fun it's been almost eight
months now so we're just having so much
fun we're just enjoying our time
together and he lived in Utah and I
lived here so it was kind of hard when
we weren't together but now it's just
it's been so fun and he's so supportive
of all this stuff I mean it's a little
crazy because he's a mechanical engineer
so this world is like different worldly
different but he's having so much fun
just being here and experiencing a new
adventure and you're still both young
and a young marriage but our kids and
everything in the future oh definitely
in the future like the far far future
but definitely there we're definitely
excited for kids we have a lot of nieces
and nephews that we love a lot so
that'll keep us preoccupied for now
other than the living in separate cities
has there been other challenges of
balancing work and married life there's
definitely challenges still I mean I
think everybody can agree if you are in
a relationship and you you know have a
career it's definitely hard
balance those two but you know we make
it work just like everybody else and if
it's worth it then you'll make it work
so I think the the biggest challenge for
us is just during the show I am
constantly at the studio like I spend
more time with my partner than I do with
my husband what he does not like but
that's just the way it is it's your job
it's my job and that's and he totally
gets it so I think that's been the
hardest challenge just being away for so
long but we've been able to kind of like
integrate that with our personal life as
well so like we'll go to dinners with
them and like we'll just stay really
close got it all right back to the show
Kim has an idea of a male cast member
who could come on Chad from The
Bachelorette
did you watch The Bachelorette at all oh
yeah I'm a very big fan of the bachelor
bachelorette bathroom paradise the whole
immaculate franchise bachelor everything
I love it yeah so Chad that would be
interesting I don't know if I had one
but um I'd love to have them on you guys
watch some interesting clips and stuff
does let the dance on snapchat
oh really yeah but it's like just a lot
of air like gyrating Oh sexual oh okay
yes so again I don't want too much fun
it would fit great TV I would love just
to watch it fun we cannot wait to watch
you on season 23 of Dancing with the
Stars hopefully you got a good partner
in the next few days I know I've already
cross my fingers and pray for me it's
gonna be awesome
leave in the comments below who do you
want her partner to be this year who's
your dream Casper we're gonna wrap this
up for now but thank you so much for
stopping by
bye guys